so then that's how I got into Hollywood
Martin Sheen uh saw one of my anti-war
films and said I'd like you to fly out
to California so this is like this is
like a 2004 or something Charlie Sheen's
dead yeah yeah so that's how I met
Charlie Sheen so I'm at their house in
Malibu and that'd be a party and they're
there and there's like you know all of a
sudden uh Anthony Hopkins comes over and
it's like I'm sitting at their house and
they're they're watching one of my
documentaries tell me how great I am so
I think I'm a leftist because it's
anti-war which I am anti-war says is a
populist as a conservative as a person
and then Emilio Estevez comes over and
then also Charlie Sheen comes over and
goes hey man I'll fly out here next time
I want you to blow up on back then he
was with um he was off the drugs then he
was smoking cigarettes he was with uh
the dark the hot girl that was the girl
before that who's the one that's in
Starship troops oh Denise Richard that's
what he was married to as kids yeah yeah
so I'm used to go stay in his house his
kids were there you're staying with
Charlie Sheen oh yeah yeah buddy invite
me to the party next time Alex well no
I've stayed with him when he went
downhill
he used to like hey my house is always
here man and listen you can use all my
cars here and here drop my Porsche it's
like 800 horsepower first gear it was
like 60 miles an hour yeah and I was
like I I I and I've driven sticking good
but I had to like turn it around and
bring it back to his house he said hey
man I want some Taco Bell he could take
the Porsche and get me some down the
hill seriously and I'm like I didn't
bring back oh can I drop another car go
back to what was happening go back to
this part Charlie
look at these guys I mean you look you
look like you were you were in good
shape he looks like he was he was rough
right there tiger blood so as you were
saying about the Hollywood so
um yeah and so then I got to know all
these other people those were off-record
stuff but I mean like he he had to go to
dinner with Buzz Aldrin and buzzer all
about the aliens and the secret bases
and the Obelisk and how they're gonna
find water in two years we're gonna let
the Indians find it and two years later
I'm gonna I'm in an airport and there's
a newspaper saying and I mean just the
most wacky stuff so so then I start
knowing all these other holiday people
because I was going on TV shows and like
some some reality shows about conspiracy
did a whole bunch of them five or six of
them I probably weren't that and so I
was on on a lot of TV programs and I was
doing voiceovers doing real well
man then I just this is probably like
16 years ago or so I knew some folks
they go listen you think Hollywood's
cool he goes this was a Charlie some
other people they go they go there's
like three groups which is people that
are here that make the money and then
you try to live outside the area and
then they're scientologists and then
there really is like a cult CIA devil
horse person and I didn't run this from
Martin Sheen or Charlie Sheen for other
people and it was like yeah they've got
these Cults but they all feed into this
larger CIA group and they brand the
women on their bellies and all and that
was Nexium and then they've got these
islands where they get these politicians
and scientists and people to compromise
them and it's all run by MI6 CIA Mossad
and they fly them out to these islands
and he goes and they're not just having
sex with kids he goes they also that's
the entry door and I learned this from
more people and I found it from other
folks and then I talked to entertainers
and then I talked to well-known
musicians and like that's why a lot of
them just leave because
um this happened to Mark Dice who's you
know been friends with forever he got
offered a major show
by the largest uh reality TV show group
and this is like 10 years ago now and
they get him in there at the end of it
and they say well here's the last thing
we want you they're a huge show with a
huge um with one of the Motley Crew guys
it was Nikki Sixx and the head of the
company goes but we want you to pleasure
salt to Lucifer and Mark said well I'm a
Christian to go well we know you say you
are but let's just get this out of the
way and he says is this a joke they said
no I'm deadly serious with you now
that's just one guy that will go public
I I got told that and and I've and I've
had a lot of meetings I have meetings
with Bilderberg Group members I've had
memes with all these folks and they're
off record me so I never talk about them
but one time
the head of the Kissinger group rothkop
in front of my producer said we want you
to come work for us we want you to come
to New York next week we're gonna you
know there's only a few thousand people
in the super class we want you to lead
uh you know basically the the populist
Liberty Movement but you'll get to see
at the table but you'll have to do what
we tell you but you'll get some you'll
you'll get to have some input you can be
on your Crusade and fail or you can join
us so that was offered in front of John
Harmon my producer I said this off
regularly said no just join us but that
wasn't satanism
the way they said it there but it's
always the same speech and and so I have
repeatedly uh had people one time I had
this major executive trying to give me a
10 million year contract and multiple
multi-book deals every year and they
said you just got to come in and do the
show but we'll control what we do and
I'm sitting there and this guy's wife
comes in and we're up at this big
high-rise you know uh
corporate office and This Woman's super
beautiful and they go I hear you like to
have fun you want to have sex with my
wife right now she thinks you're hot she
wants to have sex what do I need to do
they need to get on my knees and have
you sign this contract then another time
they offer you this deal absolutely
another time they sent this famous CIA
guy same deal I I meet with him all the
stuff he gets on his knees
so and that's what these people do
because they want that baseball card
they want to own Alex Jones and they're
going to want to own you and when you
get popular and they're going to want
and they're super crazy stuff like like
I'd already heard about this but I was
talking to a very well-known individual
I can't tell the whole story but
he was being flown by the same guy that
was flying the king of a major Middle
Eastern country and I'm not going to say
this we don't get the guy in trouble
this is on a big jump big jet jumbo
large full body Jet and this is this is
the chief pilot and he tells this guy
that I know doesn't BS he tells them
listen I've only done this you're like
once
has done all these ndas all this other
stuff we get on the jumbo jet with the
with the king of this major deal and
it's and and there's other Jets a couple
Jets following with his family because
that's how they do it
and he says go to these coordinates and
he wouldn't even say what ocean but he
knows there's nothing there and he goes
no go there they go there it's a private
island Beyond it's like seven star if
such a thing existed and no homeless
nothing nothing but billionaires but
it's it's just everything and and
telling you that's the level of this
control and I guarantee you they've
approached Joe Rogan because he's I'm
not gonna he hasn't told me but I could
tell uh you know I mean the last year
he's gotten the talking to him he said
screw him I could tell uh we hang out
and have dinner and talk some of the
point is I can just tell because I know
people get these speeches
is there another Epstein Island but well
that's the level the level of yes
absolutely when you say an island yeah I
mean I'm being told by well-known people
that man hey you think Hollywood's cool
you know what are you gonna do when
you're at a party some night
and they bring a 16 year old girl in
there and start having sex with her and
just implicate you're in the building
wow and that's why you need to not go to
that party tonight you need to get out
of here okay that's the kind of stuff
really prominent people you know you're
like telling you this place is dangerous
and you need to watch out because I was
getting deep into Hollywood I mean I was
I was at parties with the biggest names
but I mean you just have to think about
if if uh Rob what is this you pulled up
here this nxivm that's the uh sex cult
that Alex was talking about in Los
Angeles name of commonly used to
describe the personality Cult of
imprisoned racketeer and sex offender
Keith Rainier is also trademark name
defunct corporation that renewer founder
which provided seminars and videos in
the field of human potential development
the United States seized ownership of
the organizational related entities and
personal Intel intellectual property
through asset forfeiture allowing
Revenue to con
that's just one feeder group
so they have all these little you know
kind of like the Hells Angels or the
Mongols will have a sub motorcycle gang
that's not members but works for them
yeah and then and then they all have
guys under them
and so that's how they work so
But but so I was told by a lot of people
that this stuff was going on and the and
the Hollywood was run by basically I
mean if you've seen that new movie I
forget the name of it it was pretty
powerful it's actually somewhat historic
it's a composite
um Babylon about Hollywood
uh that the latest movie that just came
out was the movie or documentary the
freedom no I think it was called Babylon
Hollywood Babylon how to find that room
it just came out I watched it like what
was the problems theaters
it was in theaters
it was a big movie what was what was the
premise of the movie it was the early
days of Hollywood in the uh in the 20s
and 30s
um
Hollywood yeah I see it right here right
there Hollywood Babylon
yeah
click it
I think we were black comments Margot
Robbie
Brad Pitt
anyways you watch that that's that stuff
went on go to the poster on the right
Road or the poster right there punch in
is that it yeah and so this is basically
Brad Pitt Margot Robbie Babylon this is
based on real like the Patriot the Mel
Gibson was a composite of three stories
but they're true and and that's the same
thing for a lot of these movies but but
I read the research on this this is a
composite of real stuff that went on in
Hollywood so this devil worship
cannibalism uh eating rats uh while you
know all having sex with hot women
because to them it's not to have a hot
woman now you need to have it Brad Pitt
is in it Michael Robbie's son yeah
why would they make a movie trashing
their own industry
I think they think it's cool and uh is
is it coming from a place of like
exposing the truth or is it coming from
a place of this is the level you make it
if you become very famous they basically
say this is Hollywood's Tombstone the
movie and and
they just say this is who we are and
Hollywood's dead now so now here's the
story of how we began and that maybe
we'll be reborn somewhere else it's
pretty strange right there because we're
all in the phase now of even the system
has to expose itself now because this is
the season of that and and so but I'm
telling you watch this movie this is
devil worship in the 20s and 30s they
call it a black comedy drama punch in
Rob
epic period black comedy trauma
you watched this whole movie yes
but what I saw Bohemian Grove had major
shades of this and if I can't just
because I never do this on Big Shows
we're struggling to stay on air we still
have a huge audience that Tunes in and
our work gets seen everywhere but it's
kind of like I'm in a prison and then I
send letters out so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]